foreign
[Music]
think at this point Nick Gray yes we're
ready for questions all right so what
we're going to do is we're gonna do a
little q a and we'll Riff on some of
that stuff fantastic let's see uh please
can I have house lights and I would like
to see Hands Up For questions for the
panelists I see one here in the center I
see one over here thank you guys I'm
gonna ask you to raise your hands again
and we're gonna try to go through these
fast please say who your question's for
uh my question is for Sam
uh what do you think podcasting will be
in 10 years positive or negative
what
no like you want to have some light
discussion uh where will podcasting be
so when she was Sean's idea to start our
podcast he came to me and he's like I've
got this finished episode will the
hustle publish it be our publisher and
the original version of MFM was not what
it is now it was him interviewing people
and it was still good and then one day
someone didn't show up to the studio
time that we had already paid for and
he's like oh just come in and do the
thing that we do and that's kind of how
it came to be and by the way you know
that story is not true right
no that's not actually how it came about
it I did not know that because I've
heard you tell this I'm like is he
telling us because you're not a guest
Bail no I told you that what happened
was it was a good time to come clean
right in front of us in our 500 closest
friends
what happened was the hustle wasn't
promoting the podcast enough and I was
like how do I get them to promote it
maybe I could tell them what's in it for
them maybe I could make better content
or maybe I could just invite Sam on the
podcast and he will for sure make them
promote it and so you guys are launching
Trends and I was like hey come on and
let's just [__] about upcoming
Trends startups I was like they have to
promote that episode because it's like
that's their thing
well
they call this The Prestige yeah you
honey potted me it worked my point being
when we got into this I thought it was a
I thought podcasts were stupid I was
like ah it's played out there's too much
and what I've learned I'm not gonna
entirely answer your question because
the answer is I don't know but I'm gonna
try and get around to it what I've
learned
is I think it's the most powerful medium
that we've ever come across so like
because when you're in this is it sounds
weird but when you're in someone's ear
it's like literally the headphones
matter when you're in someone's ear for
like 40 or 50 minutes per session like
three times a week it's insane how what
people learn about you it's way better
than like an eight minute uh YouTube
video so where do I think you I don't
know Andrew what do you think is gonna
go right so Andrew owns a podcasting
company yeah I own a company called
supercast
um and we help um like huberman and
other people monetize their podcast and
I was talking to the guy who runs it
actually yesterday weirdly and he said
that podcasting there's 62 penetration
in the United States so like 62 percent
of people are aware but there's only two
billion dollars in the market so
podcasting advertising dollars and stuff
and you think about like FM radio and
how big that market is I would just look
at FM radio and be like okay how big is
that and if every podcast was monetized
like FM radio it's probably that big so
it can probably like 20x 50x 100x I
don't know would you agree that
podcasting is the hardest medium to grow
yeah for sure I think that it has the
benefit of what you said that people
become really loyal very quickly but
it's the hardest to grow so you can go
on Tick Tock and you'll get a bunch of
followers
but if you said hey we're doing a live
show in Austin you're not going to get
anybody to show up in fact there's funny
tick tocks of these tick tockers doing
meet and greets that no one shows up to
because they thought if I have a hundred
thousand followers for sure people are
going to show up and so you know the the
trust is what matters not how many fans
well also I'd say it's I'd argue it's
the best medium to have subscribers on
because someone will see it in their app
and there's no algorithm that's going to
get in your way whereas on YouTube or
something yeah you've got the same
monetization opportunities of doing
events and you know promotions and ads
and all the other stuff but it's so easy
for the algo just to go away from you
and you forget about the person the
problem with it is unlike blog articles
and things like that you can't fake it I
can fake a Blog article and get you to
click on it
um it's podcasting is very hard for that
reason and I always like joke but I'm
like the best way to circumvent
someone's [__] detectors to not
[__] and it's like the best way to
like get successful in podcasting is to
be talented or like be really good and
that's super hard because you don't
actually have to be good at a bunch of
like blogging and even newsletter
writing you should have to be pretty
good but you can kind of be pretty bad
and still succeed podcasting is a lot
more challenging who else hey this
question is for Sean and Sam I'm
building a website called askthepod.com
it's meant to be AI companion for
podcasts so you can listen to the
episode and go back ask questions what
do the books mentioned what are the
links mentioned so is it okay to add my
first million
the pitches are less there's a moment
yes next question who's got a question I
want to see one from over here hand out
pass the mic down please hey guys thanks
so much love the podcast my questions
for Sam I'm I'm a copywriter and I'm
just wondering what your number one tip
is for getting better at writing
persuasively and specifically copy
just some boring questions guys
so copying word for word other people's
work so what I like to do is I print out
like whether it's a movie script or a
great like blog article or a really good
piece of copy that I like and I copy it
word for word and it's almost like
learning music you like play other
people's music and you like see the
texture of what makes greatness and then
you like steal from a bunch of different
places and make your own and that's what
I like to do spend six months doing that
one hour every day you'll get pretty
good awesome thanks
should we get people to line up maybe
just so that there's no delay sure yep
I'm open to that if you have a question
which we would love to hear questions
coming
it's a good question where have you been
all my life man Marilyn
[Laughter]
you're one joke away from getting this
next seat on the on the stage here so I
mean uh he said a lot of the past guys I
hate the podcast my fault but um you
hate podcasts huh you hate the podcast
no it's sarcasm oh
can we [__]
hey excellent question come on up the
next one is Austin
all right this question's for Andrew uh
what have you learned uh the
commonalities of the bottom 20 of
Investments that you've had versus the
top 20 what differentiates the bottom 20
top 20 the biggest that I do the big the
biggest mistake I would say over and
over and over again is when I bet on the
business not the jockey right so I get
really excited about the business and
the business model and I go oh my God
this is a great idea if I ran this or
someone like me ran this this would be
amazing even if I don't believe in the
entrepreneur and I've realized that
betting on the entrepreneur is 100 of
the game right because they'll figure it
out but don't you want to have have a
business that any idiot can run oh yeah
for sure but I'm saying like the ones
where I've lost I actually haven't lost
that much money in businesses where I'm
buying the whole thing almost all of
those work it's the ones where I'm doing
venture or I'm betting on something or
I'm trying to start a business that's
why I lose all my money
excellent next question hi Massey um so
I wanted to ask how do you feel about
Community Building obviously it's become
really big for creators how do you see
it in the podcast genre sort of that
async communication with your fandom and
building those super fans
yeah I think for a podcast you don't
really want to build a community as such
you want to build a cult so so basically
you're like what is it that we believe
that not everybody believes and let's
put that on blast and then a bunch of
other people who believe that too are
gonna be like finally someone said it or
like finally they they do things the way
I do things like for most of you here I
I would bet like hands up if you
consider yourself like I'm a real fan
like I truly love the Pod I feel like
when you guys are doing the Pod I could
be sitting there right with you guys
kind of bullshitting I bet like leave
your hands up for a second
um
put your uh leave your hand up if the
following statement is true
it's not that you learned that much from
us but it's kind of like you feel like
you're hanging out with us that we are
like you and that if we just happen to
have met we would have been friends
so like most people leave their hand up
right I kind of confuse them
but it's that's kind of what you go for
I think most people when they do content
they're trying to be heavily
informational and they think they're
talking down to people they're thinking
they're educating them and whatnot what
we do is we just talk about stuff we're
interested in that we think and then it
just happens to attract a bunch of other
people who think the way we do and
that's kind of like more like a cult
than it is a community of people where
we all gather around and serve each
other human is a great example of that
where like we were just talking about
this backstage actually he does these
two-hour crazy podcasts on like weird
nerdy science stuff but he makes these
subtle little comments about his dog and
he seems like a real sweetie and all
these things and people connect with him
and he's handsome what does he look like
shirtless ridiculous okay so Mike
huberman invited me over to his house
and he goes let's do a sauna and a cold
plunger I've never met him before and I
was traveling with my girlfriend and I
was like oh like Zoe do you want to come
with me and we'll go to huberman's she
didn't know who he is and she's like no
I'm good and we get there he takes his
shirt off and he's just shredded like
you could like shred cheese on his chest
eight pack bulging arms tattoos and I'm
there and I'm just like folding myself
into a little ball and I was like thank
God I didn't bring her
our software is the worst have you heard
of HubSpot see most crms are a cobble
together mess but HubSpot is easy to
adopt and actually looks gorgeous I
think I love our new CRM our software is
the best HubSpot grow better
[Music]
we'll do uh two or three more yeah all
right next question
hey guys
um my question is what can partners of
Founders do to support them on their
journey I see that some of your wives
are here just wondering yeah let's hand
the mic to them let's see what they have
to say we uh don't do it
yeah
everyone we've gotten the requests where
people have like bring your wives on and
we're like no we're not doing that this
is the one thing I have don't give it to
her
um
my
uh
I've done a good job of partnering in
business and in relationships with
people who are very emotionally stable
because I am not and that and that has
been awesome and so basically like
there's been many many many times where
I'm laying on the floor and I say
[__] this I'm out this sucks I'm bailing
I'm gonna quit and she'll just like sit
there and be like okay okay and then
just like not really reply other than
like all right you done now and and that
has been like pretty wonderful to have
someone who's like emotionally stable to
balance out someone who's pretty
neurotic
um for me I remember when we were gonna
like I always say oh we sold bibo as if
it was like this easy thing that was for
sure gonna happen what actually happened
was the business wasn't really going the
way I wanted
and I was like I gotta just do something
else so I said I'm gonna try my best to
sell this business but if it doesn't
sell
just gonna shut it down I don't know I
don't know what I'm gonna do next we're
gonna just I'll figure something else
and I just gotta change it up and I went
to my wife Sony who's right here and I I
said hey I'm thinking about doing this
we were pregnant pregnant with our first
and it's like hey how do you feel about
me either selling this or more likely
it's just not gonna work out and we get
zero we have no job no health insurance
and like I don't know what I'm gonna do
next but I just kind of failed for five
years straight so that's the track
record I got going here and she was like
let's go for it like no hesitation was
just like I believe in you let's do this
um like no kind of like go the go for it
go for the upside and not worrying about
what happens if things go wrong that
really helped me because I was like oh
cool like even if we strike out I don't
have to I already beat myself up I'm not
gonna get beat up more if things don't
go well and I don't have to keep hedging
it's like seriously workout muttering
like broke ass [__]
see
so I would say I would say there's three
things so number one empathy but empathy
without understanding is useless so like
in previous relationships it would be
like oh my God you know this person at
work has given me so much trouble and
the reason is that they want stock
options and that means this or whatever
and the previous Partners would glaze
over and they'd go oh babe that's so
hard but it was like Hollow right
there's no understanding and so what I
found really works is actually not like
going into business and like obsessing
over it but just making a bit of an
effort to understand the actual problem
and like you know for example like my
girlfriend will listen to my first
million or my girlfriend will read I
mean
so she'll make a bit of effort
um and then what was my third thing [__]
brain fart
I'll remember it later I'll tell you
great so for those that are in the line
I'm gonna walk down you're very quickly
going to say your question I'll try to
do five or ten real quick they will not
be answering them but they may give an
answer later first up what was the
reasoning behind going public taking
tiny public and what was the biggest
lesson learned excellent next question
question for Andrew I was curious about
your follow-up to your kind of personal
episodes about your dip emotionally and
what that's been the last like 12 months
for instance awesome a few more Andrew
how did you start and grow your agency
business excellent next yeah for the
panel uh built a few businesses that did
Millions now I found myself complacent
lacking purpose yeah I'd just like to
know your answer to that
uh okay all right next one without
turning it into Billy of the week
Andrew's Impressions on meeting my
boss's bosses bosses boss Michael Dell
this week the stuff that you didn't put
on Twitter already
yep we're gonna pause for those of you
that are standing waiting for questions
take a seat and we'll do another round
of q a so I think I think the first one
was going public and why and I would say
that going public is if you're an
investor it represents the greatest
opportunity right you can raise Capital
at a great valuation you can buy it back
when it's cheap you can use your Equity
to buy businesses those are just kind of
boring business reasons to be honest the
reason kind of relates to my dip so over
the last like two or three years I went
through a bit of a funk and it came from
this feeling of like
I don't know why I'm making more money I
don't have a thing right so when I
started uh it was because I was like
okay I want to wake up whenever I want
and I don't want to have a job and then
it was like okay I want to have a sweet
house and a car and then I was like okay
I got a sweet house and a car
um now I want to pay off my parents
mortgage and then after that and then it
was like okay I want enough money that I
can be fine and stop working but after
that point which I reached seven or
eight years ago
um I just didn't know what to do with it
and I tried all these different things
you know I would go and like you know
buy wine and fancy cars and go on fancy
vacations and all these things and
nothing really made me happy and so over
the last couple years I've been trying
to figure that out and I tweeted about
this earlier and I mentioned this but
I've been really admiring people that do
two things one is they use money
um to live life in a very interesting
and creative way so Nick is a great
example of that Nixa multi-millionaire
he accidented his business he's done
very very well and he just has an
Investment Portfolio on autopilot
invested in Tesla really early on and
now he just focuses on meeting
interesting people so that's one piece
and I've done a lot of that just meeting
interesting people and then two is
figuring out how to give it away and
actually impact my community so like I
did that local journalism thing I think
you guys know about and going public
in Canada it allows me to actually give
my shares to my foundation so I can
actually do that so it enables that
Andrew did the biggest Flex on us when
we saw him for dinner the other night
we're like oh what have you been doing
and he goes philanthropy they were like
oh okay okay big guy and then he didn't
pay for dinner
he didn't dedicate to donate to the Sam
and Sean Foundation yeah
the 500 dinner
um and the other question was about
Michael Dell you met Michael Dell this
weekend yeah Michael Dell
um he was so
okay so like Michael Dell is like what
you hope capitalism is right like I met
him and he was the nicest most
down-to-earth engaged Pleasant guy and I
spent a lot of rich people I've met
billionaires multi-billionaires he's
worth 50. so he's worth like 10x any of
the other people and he was just really
genuine and nice and I asked him like
okay what are your vices like how are
you not like you you have like a Super
PAC like some weird libertarian Island
where you like hunt and kill people are
you building like penis Rockets to Mars
like what are you doing and he just goes
no I got a couple nice houses I've got a
jet I just like to work and build my
business and I give it all away to my
foundation and I was like okay that's
pretty cool he's like the human version
of a Dell computer
[Music]
totally but like a nice a nice computer
that works well for you
[Music]